I was gonna brandy you I don't like
referring to myself as your mother no
here we go I need to make more video to
this brand girl came into a perfect
opportunity to force myself to make a
video and three it's a company that I
actually really really like I'm not
gonna [ __ ] you guys
20:19 know we're both only small amounts
of bullsh consistently we're done not
help we're talking about hellofresh
today they have sponsored today's video
genuinely love this company I spent all
morning and afternoon and recording new
episodes it's not too deep shot with Jax
films and Elle Mills today I mean a
would a yin-yang of fo the new YouTube
royalty I don't mean that disingenuously
I actually like sincerely mean that I'm
gonna work on sincerity maybe I'll take
some time off I'm not bullshitting I
practice being sincere oh no that's
called acting I'm gonna get better at
acting this year and I'm tired and I
want to make myself a meal at the end of
the day I don't want to just order food
I want to feel like I like really
provided for myself yeah unending
domestic goddess that I am hella fresh
is a how would you describe it there's
no one else here to answer that question
that's definitely a me question Oprah's
basically like a meal delivery service
that is just the most thoughtful and
idiot-proof system I've ever used it
make conquering the kitchen easy with
delicious and simple meals yeah that's
ad copy well how did I act it okay this
is kind of my favorite alternative
providing myself food at the end of the
day when I'm very very tired you know
order all different meal plans from them
and you can customize based on like your
dietary restrictions etc based on your
own personal religious or political
preferences etc I don't know you but I'd
like to get to know you from a distance
and not for a very long time
so there's menu pre-measured ingredients
for the amount of recipes that you room
sign up for and then they send you these
recipe cards six different photos that
you can follow along and I'm a visual
learner because reading you know be pre
focused to do reading so I like pictures
they pre measure everything so you'd
like kind of cooking but not really
cookie they really really try to make it
hard for you to put it up maybe today
will find a way I thought that this
video would just be me looking and
chatting with
it's basically like I invited you over
to have some drinks and talk at the end
of the night I was like no no I'll cook
for us it'll be fun we're doing this
connecting from a distance I basically
have three plans to choose from classic
veggie family classic that your family
sounds like Nickelodeon cartoon and they
make it super easy that you can switch
your plans if you want to if your tastes
change or if you get a new family I
don't know but I want to get know we got
pork and poblano tacos hey sweet as
honey chicken q and this is the one
we're going for today meatloaf ala mom
please do not consider me I'm if
anything a fun drunk ass did your mom
make you meatloaf growing up why is that
a mom thing I've never actually made a
meatloaf before in my life oh this is
gonna be fun and firsts this is the
longest intro to get to the cooking part
I know I understand that I'm here too
let's do it
look at that if I try to buy ingredients
at the store to make a recipe when I
feel the whim of it all you guys watched
my matzo ball soup video I matzo ball
soup for like four days straight every
meal if my stomach up real real solid
but look that's not the right salad not
how it went down but it went down so
let's do this how are you guys look
we're already doing the talking thing
I'm gonna wash my hands oh my gosh I'm
so excited to make meatloaf Wow I'm in
my 30s preheat the oven to 450 degrees I
have a secondary camera let's do this
too why not we want the brand to
continue to like us and potentially make
a longer-term deal with them all right
wash and dry all produce half and peel
the shallots rate one half with a grater
intimate involvement other having set
aside Mitch gonna strip time in some
stems of roughly chopped have carrots I
like scale potato and cut it slice it's
like a choice I'm bad at reading I
didn't retain a single thing that I just
read out laughs I just got lost in
thought trying to make a Ohio joke but
instead of OEO a potay so shout outs are
just like if we're all onions Rosanna
pansino sash Alex where did it all go
what happened here I don't know if this
is correct look like half a step in over
RT not doing well good game look at this
remember me as I am because I'm gonna be
different after this you guys go aside
okay we got garlic here oh my god
a stop cursing trip the time queue this
sexy music what oh I forgot that we're
supposed to be talking and connecting on
a deeper more intimate but also
friendship base level this is what I
always think is really funny about like
cooking shows they really try to
personalize the meal by telling like
anecdotes based on the meal they're
cooking what is one from me with
meatloaf Oh meatloaf artists you guys
never see that stop google it
France probably not gonna let me say
that in this video have the carrots
lengthwise these are already fueled and
they look clean so I'm not gonna wash
them in that kitchen I will have these
fun friends I'm gonna peel the potato
and cut into thin slices candid
everywhere yes skin everywhere my
library open check we are tired I'm so
amped for this meatloaf I'm officially
old we're officially on to step two the
carrots and potatoes on a baking sheet
with some olive oil
I really thought this year I wanted to
have fun and stay relevant with my
audience and the best way to do it let's
just make a meatloaf and I need to
season this with salt and pepper some
pepper always reminds me of loose
cleaners because I'm a talking married
couple
salt and pepper has anyone checked on
Steve are we worried about him made with
love roast this until tender for 20-25
minutes we'll add more ingredients to
the sheet after seven minutes says the
recipe oh that's so cryptic step 3 this
is where it gets good
I got a photon I caught myself that I
kitchen my rules Cheers
okay oh my god we're making the meat
Lois now everyone this is not a drill
we've gotten to the part where we're
making the goddamn meatloaf to LeBeau
put the grated shallot 1/4 cup of panko
breadcrumbs then the ground beef I'm
sorry anyone that is vegan or vegetarian
I respect you and your lifestyle choices
to stop me where's the beef in its own
little tiny prison that I can't get it
out of God is this oddly sexual wash
your hands
garlic ha the time
I've already been cooking for 30 minutes
which is already longer than the recipe
has suggested so it would take a normal
person we're gonna gently go - we're
hands and shape into - 1 inch tall
loaves - 1 inch tall loaves I mean
that's also very complicated and
hilarious way to describe someone with a
nice ass oh my god these are gonna be
tiny cute mitla oh my god that's a lung
if you look like a loaf okay we're get
you excited I'm all over the place says
what's the veggies have roasted for
seven minutes remove the sheet pan from
the oven give them a toss and place meat
loaves on the same sheet then brush the
tops of the loaves with one tablespoon
of ketchup we sent more they said in
parentheses good looking out and return
the sheet to the oven and continue
roasting until mellows are cooked
through 15 18 minutes now while the
meatloaf and the vegetables cook we're
gonna make a house we're gonna make our
gravy we're doing it we're on step 5
we're gonna melt half a tablespoon of
butter in a medium pan over medium heat
and then add the minced shallot the
remaining time and cook tossing until
soften for three or four minutes then
sprinkle flour into the pan stirring
vigorously to combine whisking stock
concentrate and add 1/2 cup of water
bring to a simmer so that bubble until
thick and saucy three to four minutes
seasoned with salt and pepper again did
not retain any of what I just said but
here we go it's kind of looking the
gravy sort of she thick y'all she fit oh
I forgot to be talking to you and make
me a connection so anyone sad out there
doing sat tell me why specifically cool
oh my god I think we just made great we
got calm down still fun cooking is oh
whoa Wow don't look at my butt but you
can whoa it's getting hot in here so
chop up all your cloves I don't like me
either right now oh yeah here look at
what's going on in here look at this
look at that look at that I good job
don't the meat loaves and the vegetables
finish cooking and the gravy continue to
get back and then we played it I'm so
excited
well I have a second I should check the
talking points and make sure that I have
hid all the things that they have asked
me to because I am as we all know an
idiot oh that's right you guys give it a
little fresh special offer that's the
whole point of this
a total of $80 off with eight eight free
meals in your first month of signing up
for hello fresh if you go to hello fresh
calm and use the offered all links
obviously down below but go to hello
fresh com use the promo code get $80 off
and eight free meals in your first month
that you signed up that's a good deal
and also learn some stuff about yourself
oh absolutely learning about you uh well
who's got regrets
anyway let's put the food continue
cooking it will be back oh my gosh oh
it's almost done this is like when
you're excited for like a friend to come
over I mean definitely you were supposed
to be that friend to come over but like
when you're excited that like your bed
your friend is coming over to hang out
me looks about to come over she's here
she's here oh my gosh look at those
little lady lumps I don't know how to
tell the meat is done but you know what
they say the only safe place to assume
is around potentially raw meat yeah that
looks kind of good oh my god
hi I did this I made you I made you I
made you all so my impression of if I
was actually your mom okay let's taste
this meatloaf Allah mom I'm so proud of
myself
this tastes so damn good oh we did it
no I did it I did oh my god this is so
good all right well you guys and I just
choked and died on camera wouldn't that
be the most epic win and a brand new
guys thank you for watching this video
thank you hello fresh for sponsoring
this video and give me a reason to turn
the camera off other than that I don't
know and the fun part is that when you
cook for yourself at home first is going
to a restaurant you can eat your food
however unrefined Italy as you want you
can also commit to the idea that
unrefined Italy is a word